on va voir tout de suite trois
personnages qui vont venir faire leurs
prestations ces trois personnages que
vous connaissez bien c'est julien
courbet qui voulait absolument vous
faire cette surprise se déguiser en
shakira parce que vous la faites très
bien
[Applaudissements]
m
honnêtement j'avais peur d'être ridicule
et maintenant que je me vois ben je le
suis fait bien céline dion j'adore qu'on
fasse un web on va la bombe à la balle
et la peau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toi
arrêtez je comprends que du coup lui il
est il a été génial je me dis là toi et
il peut dans l'exagération y en a qui va
le faire très très premier degré et
c'est matthieu delormeau qui va nous
faire beyoncé
[Applaudissements]
sa mémoire
activision vient d'arrêter à bwin et
party avec lui et cela va jusqu'à 9h30
comme ça les chaussures mon handicap est
un petit peu pourquoi j'étais moins à
l'est puisque la danse j'aime bien sûr
c'est pas la peine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui là c'est alors florent réseau ils
sont tous les trois font que je vote non
ah bah si vous allez parce que vous
allez repartir avec une des trois places
à la la on laisse tomber m
bravo à tous les trois ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]